Hi.
I'm Rick Viscomi, and
I make YouTube fast.
In this video,
I'm going to share
how we test web
performance and a few tips
for doing the same
on your own website.
The two test methodologies
that we're going to look at
are real user monitoring, or
RUM, and synthetic testing.
Real user monitoring,
just as it sounds,
gathers performance
data from real users
as they browse the site.
For YouTube, this provides
us with the ground truth
about how users are
experiencing the site.
Synthetic testing, on the other
hand, is more like a laboratory
and is commonly used on demand
to analyze our particular use
case.
Both methodologies
collect performance data,
but given these
distinctions, RUM
is especially useful
for identifying
how fast the page is, and
synthetic for identifying
how to make it faster.
The simplest way to gather
and analyze RUM data
is with one of the existing
analytics products.
In fact, Google Analytics
can do this for you.
At Google, we use
a custom solution
called client side
instrumentation, or CSI.
RUM works on three basic levels.
First, we instrument
our client side code
to provide timing and page
state data to the RUM JavaScript
library.
Then, the library
packages up the data
and sends it off to the
Analytics server for later use.
And finally, the
Analytics server
provides developers with a
dashboard to view the results.
Out of the box, most RUM tools
measure the general page events
published by their
navigation timing API.
But for us, one of the most
important performance metrics
is how quickly a video plays.
The metrics you collect
should be customized
based on what your
application does
and what your users are
actually waiting for.
It's also important to include
any contextual information that
might have an effect
on performance.
For example,
YouTube users may be
exposed to
experimental features,
and we would need to
know what effect that
might have had on performance.
By keeping track
of these variables,
we're better able
to get insights
into the performance of
particular demographics.
Also, note that the CSI
beacon is sent unobtrusively
after the critical path
and video playback.
This helps to ensure
that testing does not
interfere with the
user experience.
To analyze the performance data,
we turn to the CSI dashboard.
Here, we're able to look at the
change in performance over time
and compare experiments
against controls.
For example, in
this chart, we're
comparing the results of an
experiment against the baseline
control.
The experiment times
are lower or faster
until this last point.
We can use the CSI
dashboard to slice data
by various demographics
to understand
why this is happening, and
when we break the data down
by browser, it becomes
clear that browser B
is responsible for
the regression.
It's also worth mentioning
that, because we gather data
from so many users--
all of whom have
different devices on
different networks--
we typically look at
the 50th percentile,
or the median value, to give
us a representative view
of the performance data.
OK.
That's it for RUM.
Now let's compare it
to synthetic testing.
For that, we use WebPagetest,
which is a free public tool.
And instead of gathering
data from real users,
we configure synthetic tests
to a particular demographic.
The tests run in a
laboratory-like environment
to mitigate the effective
network anomalies,
and this is achieved
through repetition.
So tests that are run many times
are considered to be reliable.
And, finally, when
the results are in,
we're able to analyze
our application
specific metrics along
with the test network log.
WebPagetest gives
you full control
over the type of use case
for which you want to test.
For example, we may be
interested in the Watch page
performance in Chrome
over a DSL connection.
And being a free public
tool, WebPagetests
are run on ordinary computers
connected to the internet.
To test YouTube, however, we
need more privileged access
to beta versions of the site.
So for this reason, we run
our own private instances
of WebPagetest inside of Google.
The results are shown on
a waterfall diagram, which
is a visualization of
the network activity.
In this view, we're able to
precisely see the activity
on the critical path
to video playback.
And, finally, WebPagetest
also annotates the waterfall
with our application
specific metrics.
This gives us the
necessary context
to better understand
what exactly
is contributing to slow values.
So that's it for our look
at synthetic testing.
Remember that RUM is only
as useful as the metrics
you provide.
CSI is just one of many
tools that does it,
but your solution should be just
as unobtrusive and lightweight.
Synthetic tests
should be configured
to represent common use cases,
like a particular browser,
connection, or page demographic.
Also, by locating synthetic
test machines inside
of your own network, you
can validate performance
on a staging server
before launching.
To learn more about the
NavigationTiming API,
check out the Mozilla Developer
Network article at this URL.
Or for more information
on using WebPagetest,
check out the link
over here, and also
look out for my book
coming later this year.
Thanks for watching.